once again, good afternoon,
you know what we have for those of you who
are present here, no one has lost his
son, of course this is connected, and with thoughts
about this tragedy, in this regard,
I want to say that the
language does not turn around to say some
formal standards of things related to the
expression of condolences, but  I want
you to know
I personally, the entire leadership of the country,
we share this pain,
we understand that
nothing can replace the loss of a son, the loss of a
child,
especially for mothers
who
We owe everything to the birth
that I
bring up,
but I want to know that we ourselves share this pain
and of course we will  do everything so
that you don’t feel
forgotten,
it’s clear that life is more complicated and diverse
than what is shown on
TV screens or even on the Internet,
nothing can be trusted at all there are a
lot of all sorts of fakes deceit lies
there are a lot of information Attacks
because in the modern world it has always
been like this  but given modern
technology, this has become especially relevant
and effective is also information, this is
also a weapon of struggle,
information attacks are one of the types of
fairly effective types of struggle